[Music]
my child self would be disappointed that
I don't love myself the drugs and it's
sad to say I feel like when I was little
always thought that we would act like if
like like in a time of like moral crisis
I always felt like you know like you'd
always do like the brave thing or the
right thing but like I was an adult I
feel like I'm really like scared and
like shy I don't think my child self
would be very proud of that so I'm not
happy
because life is pretty tough right now
and yeah and it just seems to be unto
her I smoke a lot of cigarettes she
would come me up because of that I think
I'm a lot more mean than my child so the
fact that I have tattoos I would have
been so mad at myself back then so but I
love them now
wanting more than I I should want like
being greedy with things I shouldn't
wish for
I guess my earliest sort of wish was to
be in design and fashion and the
creative field and then very quickly it
went awry and what an entirely different
direction and that's been always like a
thorn in my side but I was disappointed
for not going with it and then just last
year I finished my first fashion design
course and I'm hopefully working on a
collection and putting it out there in
the world very soon I'm not as patient
as I'd like to be
I think I could be more patient I don't
know maybe
maybe stupid but I don't like smoke I
smoke a little bit of weed and I and I
have i oh yeah I have smoked cigars and
that makes me disappointed each other
and
I wanted to be an attorney and I
currently work in a bakery
television there's a lot of parents
either news you okay you ready okay good
hi as a follow-up to her answer this is
mom
I should Turkish mother by the way after
we found this out after I spent a lot of
money with her going off to college to
pursue the law career thank you you're
so welcome
nothing I'm pretty proud of myself I
think my child will be pretty proud of
me
maybe that are still snoring that's
about it boys
I think it's pretty proud of me a lot
more quiet than I used to be I used to
be a lot more talkative to talk to a lot
more people
why do you think that is
I'm not sure I just appreciated maybe
leave my myself a little bit more
more intimidated by other people I guess
that I didn't recognize my potential and
where my two talents were as a young
person I've learned as I've gotten older
that I'm very mechanical and you know I
think I would have really enjoyed
something like being an engineer and I
end up being a schoolteacher and that
was great that was fine but I think
that's where my food gifts would have
been as being an engineer not as happy
as I want to be my got no idea um I did
not become a mailman in first grade I
wrote for my career that I wanted to be
a mailman our mail woman a mailman do
you know when I was a kid I always
wanted to be a jockey until I was like
10 no my grandfather pointed out I was
already too tall so I think my younger
self would be disappointed that I don't
do any equine activities and Ewok I
never became an actress I never became
an actress and I didn't join the United
Nations
I don't a flying car yet I shaved my
legs I really wanted to be a fire
fighter and IMAP relación out so I'm a
musician so it's a different thing it's
it's my dream but I guess I like a lot
to help people that I have not published
a book yet my child self would be
disappointed in my current grades in
school
I'm not doing as good as I was don't
know I would be
as ridiculous as it sounds I think I
don't skate as much as I my child
would've wanted me to face to skate
every day well then I can't move very
well that I can't hardly move that's it
because as a child you know I'd be
running or climbing those buildings and
stuff but now I can I can't Harvick I
can't walk hmm that I do a lot of
exercise all day my child self would be
disappointed in my current self for not
following her dreams and being scared to
follow like what's in her heart what are
your dreams I feel like my dreams its
music I'm very passionate about it and I
love music but I think like society
makes me feel like I should stay in
school and college so currently that is
what I'm doing instead of doing music
I haven't learned to surf yet
I used to want to be a freelance jazz
musician in New York and now I am going
to be a scientist studying genetics and
infectious diseases I think that I never
I never completed my my master's degree
then I got really fat that's it
that's the truth I've done a lot of
deviant things
[Music]
you leave it at that yeah then I
originally wanted to be a football
player national football what happened
well injuries life you gotta laugh at
Ronnie so that can't happen I dyed my
hair brown I told myself I'd always say
keep law and I actually ended up doing
some things that I didn't like I ended
up following someone else's dream and
not mine but a match how itself would be
happy I'm slowly trying to get back to
what I was doing probably that I didn't
go and bust the bubbles that the fellers
showing over there run up and bustles
we don't - yeah way down there he has a
thing
huge bother and the kids were going and
smashing him I don't I think I'd look
pretty silly running up and trying to
bust bust those bubbles so I'm pretty
much happy with decisions that I have
made and I what I've become and what I
who I am now and I think my just a child
it would be pretty heavy I want to
become a commercial pilot and at this
point you know I'm starting to realize
that that maybe that's what I should
have pursued I'm in finance right now
which I'm okay with but I guess I still
want to pursue that promotional airline
pilot career
it's probably something that at this
point Smee and with this point myself I
was a little kid you know
that's it I guess acting to too much
like in an adult I I think I always
thought I was a very authentic person as
a child and I'm coming to realize that I
merged myself with others it's been a
big part of this route I think my child
self would be disappointed in my merging
instead of my staying with myself what's
up guys my name is Mariah and I'm the
owner of this channel I'm also the
person behind the camera and I thought
I'd take a minute to thank all the
subscribers I gained so far and maybe
ask the new years to hit the subscribe
button if you liked this episode or if
you're a fan of my channel in general I
mean love thank you